hi guys today I'm going to talk about
extensive reading which is a
complementary mode of reading of
intensive reading which we have seen at
the other time
what is extensive reading well from the
word wealth extensive means that you are
doing something for an extensive or an
extended period of time in this case the
main goal of extensive reading is to
read for the pleasure reading reading as
much as you can and reading to get
information but also in terms of
language learning to get exposed to as
much language as you can because reading
no matter what happens even if you don't
deconstruct the text even if you don't
mark every single word it's still
reading extensively means to get exposed
to a lot of interesting ideas as as much
as obviously as well as a lot of words
and a lot of sentences so what should
you should you read if you want to do
some extensive reading well you can read
a graded readers and I quote here the
greater reader from Wikipedia they are
like easy reading and reading your easy
reading books to support extensive
reading the extensive reading approach
to teaching and learning foreign
languages you can look it up in
Wikipedia great readers are really
interesting and they're built to help
language learners to read extensively
then you can obviously read bilingual
books or you can read monolingual books
written for natives or you can read
magazines and you can read comic books
so you name it there's a lot of things
you can't read
for how long well this can vary could be
thirty minutes to one hour to two hours
to even three hours if you have the time
the play the main goal here is to read
as much as you can so it's not like
intensive reading that you have to limit
yourself to thirty minutes but you can
read for as much as you can when once
again differently from intensive reading
you can read when you feel like reading
and possibly when you are relaxed for
example at night you don't have your
level of energy or energy level doesn't
have to be necessarily very high the
normally I read at night or in the
weekend for example in the morning in
the park whatever you you want the
position of a body is important you
should not be sitting like you do with
intensive reading but you should be
relaxed you can be literally sprawled on
the couch
laying on the bed important thing is you
find a position of the body in which you
feel relaxed you feel comfortable the
level it should be the level you're at
or even lower possibly because this
allows you to enjoy the text to enjoy
anything and without having to look up
every single every single word or every
word every five five words or ten words
so that you can actually enjoy once
again extensive reading is made for the
pleasure of reading and when do you do
this well this depends on the level you
can do it at very various levels for
example if you're a d1 you can find
graded readers at that level so that
that allows you to keep reading without
having to look at words normally
extensive reading is obviously a great
when you have a level which allows you
to enjoy anything and without having to
look up words for example when you have
a c1 or even better a c2 level and this
is the natural mode and the maintaining
mode you read a lot to maintain
languages more due to expanded their
reading whatever whenever you do and
whenever you do it is greatly beneficial
remember that so thank you very much for
listening once again I my friend Kevin
Morehouse and I have written and also
hopefully awesome article about
intensive and extensive reading and you
can find more information on the blog if
you click on the link below thank you
very much for listening to me and I'm
going to talk to you very very very soon
bye
you